[Music]
all right what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
and on on this segment we have ask an
expert and we got eric here who's an
accountant
so we can ask him all of our finance
questions so what does an accountant do
and why do they dress like that like
what like a samurai accountant like a
samurai
and is that how you present yourself to
the world in your world of profession
you also told me you're a money mentor
like what are the what are the things
and services that you offer
and um you're like what's your
background got it got it man there's a
lot of questions yeah so number one what
does an accountant do accounts basically
help business owners or business
entrepreneurs reconcile and understand
how their money is
working how it's flowing in how it's
flowing out determine
if you're profitable or not we also give
guidance on how to grow and scale
companies or even like
hey if you want to sell your company how
to position your company be in the best
position to be able to sell it so that's
what accountants generally do and
there's a lot of different specialties
in it
just like a doctor a doctor could be a
heart surgeon or a brain surgeon or
a you know lung specialist or
dermatologist
my main focus is i'll purely focus a lot
on the taxation side of things
on taxation and also on mentoring
business owners on how to scale and grow
their business
so that's what i focus on doing um in
terms of my dress like usually when
folks think of an accountant
you usually think of guy with like
glasses and a pocket protector and a
calculator like hey guys let me see how
your receipts kind of like thing
and for me i've been an entrepreneur 16
i'm now turning 42 in about a month or
so
and i've always wanted to put a
different spin on accountancy like i'm
not a boring guy i love having fun and
doing cool stuff and
just this is a different way of kind of
like presenting myself that's that's
i think like actually who i am authentic
to who i am as opposed to
living that professional like accounting
type of structure you look at patch
adams
yeah the patch of accounting
i like it i like that well the
accountant or like so
i think like um what i know
traditionally of an accountant is
someone that works
in a big accounting firm
like maybe like a banker would work at
chase
right so do you have your private
practice or do you work out one of the
big
places yeah it's a good question too so
i've been an entrepreneur since i was 16
had many different businesses and i got
into the finance per
the financial planning space about 15
years ago and then i evolved into the
tax base
about 10 years ago tax and accounting
space and ironically the reason i got
into the tax side of things was
i was making a pretty good income as a
financial planner in 2008 this right
before lehman brothers collapsed
and i needed a tax deduction and i was
like what am i going to do and so my dad
for years was like hey why don't you
take an hr block tax course to learn
about taxes
and just like you fell in love with it
didn't you
well i mean actually like when my dad
told me that
like i was a rebellious asian kid like
my dad wanted to be a doctor
dentist attorney and i was like no i'll
be an entrepreneur so i've always was
like the black sheep i was like ah no
i'm not gonna do that
i ended up ironically getting into the
tax base because it just made a lot of
sense
um and it lined up with what i did and
also
in terms of how to run a business and
everything it made a lot of sense got
into the space
and for me like what i've realized about
accounting and tax
is i'm not really necessarily in love
with the tax code although i'm really
good at it what i really love doing is
work with folks on their finances
because i find that there's two things
in life that nobody talks about their
sex life and their money
and i'm not a sex therapist but i'm a
pretty good money therapist that's weird
because that's all i talk about
money and sex all the time and i and
when i talk to other people outside
of my friend group i forget how touchy
those subjects are
would you say you're better at money or
sex
[Laughter]
at this point i'm pretty even i would
say yeah
pretty even yeah even what determines if
you're good at sex like how many kids
you have
because it's like that's the end result
of how successful you were or how many
loads you blow not on yourself that's
good that's good hold on let me get my
excel spreadsheet down
so in order to become an accountant
right
did you have to go like to school or
anything because you said you've been an
entrepreneur since 16 did you do the
whole traditional schooling stuff
so i did go to college i went to rutgers
university where i actually ran into
business at the same time i was in the
car
hooking up cars and putting turbo kits
on stuff on it but i went to school for
economics and finance
i was supposed to go to business school
but i ended up focusing on my time on
operating a business
graduated from that got into various
other things prior to getting into
accounting and accounting was just
probably in the last 10 years and
accounting you could either go into the
space of being a cpa
and cpa for most folks that's either a
certified professional accountant or in
the accounting world they call it can't
pass again
you pass it once and that's it as long
as you pass you're good to go so if you
get a if you get an 80 you're good if
you have 79 you're screwed
and that's like a license or something
like
passing the bar for the lawyer correct
correct so i personally didn't focus on
that like my focus was on taxation
so i got a special designation from the
irs took a couple of years a bunch of
tests to be able to do that
but in my practice in my the business i
operate i have two cpas that work for me
and two tax repairs
so i'm not technically the cpa of the
business but i have cpas that work for
me so what's the difference like
like like let's say you're a doctor
right if you have that degree
but also you pass the medical exam or
whatever
you could you could uh prescribe
medicine right
versus someone who studied it but then
if they never got the license
what does the cpa license allow you to
do where you don't have it you can't do
this stuff
yeah that's a really good question so
cpa license think of a cpa as almost
like your general practice physician
so you're getting all of the little
pieces of each
piece of what the whole scope of
accounting is whereas my main focus is
on the taxation so i want
that designation now the things that i
can't do what is what is your
designation so it's called ea or
enrolled agent
that means i am able to represent
taxpayers and from the irs when it comes
to audit and
when it comes to tax controversy i could
represent folks in front of it like a
like a lawyer
not as a lawyer so i i'm not a tax court
practitioner
okay um but if there's a desk on it or a
field audit an otter comes out knocks in
your door
you call me up and like eric i'm in
trouble and i come out and help you out
so if i want to participate in tax
evasion you can help me do it
we can have a separate conversation off
the records off the books
off the books but you're usually dealing
with guys that might have been too busy
to deal with
maybe accounting it the right way or
whatever and they're like
oh crap the irs says that there's a
inconsistency i need help and then for
whatever reason
they don't have to deal with them you
they deal with you yeah the most common
ones i'm seeing right now is in the
cryptocurrency space
um just because cryptocurrency is kind
of like this wild west if you're in the
right place
so i've actually been teaching on
different like masterminds and different
business organizations on
how to properly do crypto taxes and also
how to properly set yourself up so
you're not paying too much in taxes how
do you
so how are they looking at crypto
because are they looking it as a
currency or like a stock
like like you know what's the what is it
categorized as
that's a good question so cryptocurrency
in general the way that you're trading
right now
isn't like currency even though it's
called currency correct
so it's kind of like a misnomer the irs
is treating it as if it's a piece of
property
so think of it like a stock you're
buying a piece of property which is one
share of let's say
apple and then when you sell the share
of apple if there's a gain or a loss
based upon what you paid for it you pay
tax on the gain or you write off the
loss
so cryptocurrency is similar in that
you're buying a piece of property one
bitcoin or one ethereum coin or one
token from an ico
and then if there's a gain you pay tax
on it either a long short term and if
there's loss
you pay you know you write off the loss
but there's a little bit more nuance to
it because there's different things like
air drops there's different things like
getting dividends by putting it like an
exo account so oh [ __ ] you actually know
some of this stuff
yeah yeah i've been on this space for a
number of years all right very cool
what's an excel account you can't just
say these i don't know
dropping stuff here what is it next to
account what is that so next was really
an interesting thing and i'm not like
super familiar with it but basically
what you're able to do is you're
able to put your coin in an account as
not like i don't really want to say it's
collateral but basically the bank holds
on to the coin
and then they actually pay you interest
a pretty high interest rate compared to
the banks right now
on the coin that they hold for you well
air drops don't have to be voluntary
either so
what if i get because i got a [ __ ] kind
of [ __ ] airdrop to me
without my permission because just my
wallet was part of it's part of
all the all the blockchain so i get
taxed on that
like if i just have that in my wallet i
didn't sell it or anything and what's
airdrop is that that's not the iphone
air driver
is like um anybody can send you a coin
right now i could just send it to your
wallet if i have your address oh free
bitcoin
right yeah if you send me a free book i
would have to pay taxes on it or
if you sold it that's my understanding
anyway so air drops can be a little bit
complicated depending on how they're
structured they can either be treated as
interest where you pay tax when you
receive it or they could be treated as
piece of property it depends on how the
air drop is set up
so if it's treated as interest you'd
basically consider that as
income so let's say you had um i forgot
a coin was
was airdropped back in 2017. there's a
ton of like [ __ ]
[ __ ] coins you used to call it right and
there's they still do there's a ton of
stuff right
so if it's treated as interest and let's
say you got a thousand coin
technically what you're supposed to be
doing is reporting it as interest
and then now you pay the tax on it now
it's sitting in your portfolio as a coin
you have a basis in then you
sell and you get a capital gain if it's
treated as property
because it's like maybe the air drop was
just basically a split off of the coin
then in that case then it's not treated
as income it's treated as as just a
split off
of your coin then you have a basis in it
and then when you sell the coin you pay
tax on it okay
so there's a lot of nuance and that's
kind of what makes crypto tax
so complicated is because there's so
many nuances in how things are
structured and it's still like the wild
west where
there's no real tax reporting outside of
the fiatu crypto on-ramps like
coinbase and stuff like that where if
you have over a number of transactions
they'll send you a 1099 that says
hey man you had all these transactions
the irish is getting reported on it
today's video is brought to you by
curology
bart do you notice something about me
that's so
different these days your face and your
skincare
yes dude oh my goodness okay so check
this out no joke okay
i've been actually using skincare for
over a year now oh [ __ ] yeah
and because curology has just been
sending me mad creams
yeah um and you know i've been pretty
much a caveman for the longest time you
know like i
really don't have a skin care routine
like i just get water
do this thing yeah be on with my day
but i realized that man i was getting
like
aging spots i'm not a young man anymore
dude i'm actually going to turn 64
tomorrow
oh [ __ ] so i was like dude it's time to
finally do something about my skin
you only like 30 something for a 64 year
old thanks bro i know
thanks thanks curology no but like yeah
so
the cool thing is um they've been
sending me packages for over a year
and i've been on this routine and what's
cool is like it's super simple
you go on their website you do this
survey and they custom
create a formula for what your needs are
needs are yeah
it's dope like i wanted like tight skin
i got like
eczema and stuff so i was like sensitive
skin and whatever whatever's right
and so they're like okay we got a joe
formula and they also have like this
moisturizer thing that comes in
where it's like to make sure that your
skin doesn't dry out like crazy
yeah so they have the formula cream they
have the moisturizer and they have a
cleanser nice so i'm
actually washing my face with
face cleanser i could tell the
difference thank you yeah it looks clean
smooth
vibrant looking if you guys want to be
as vibrant as me then make sure you
check out
curology because it is good for the soul
and the skin hole so if you're ready for
healthier skin and a routine that makes
sense
do what joe did and give curology a go
go to curology.com
off the record for a free 30-day trial
all you gotta do is pay shipping and
handling that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash off the record to unlock
your free
30-day trial see curology.com for all
the details
thank you curology thank you for my face
let's say
i have an um i have bitcoin right and
then it's 2018
and they um they forked bitcoin bitcoin
cash
i didn't participate in that they
literally just send me bitcoin cash
i get taxed on that yes you'd get tax on
that that's so lame only when you sell
it okay okay yeah
got it bitcoin cash is a little bit that
one's a bit of interesting because a
fork is
kind of different than a traditional
airdrop so you've received a coin
that maybe now has no basis because you
didn't technically pay for it right but
you're granted a coin
so now when you sell that bitcoin cash
now it's at i think it's like 1400 or
wherever it's at
and you sell it now you have the gain
from zero to 1400 so you're going to pay
the tax on that capital gain
wow so if you go from coin to coin you
don't have to pay
so that's another good question so
here's probably the best analogy let's
say you buy a
1968 ford mustang and you're driving a
ford mustang
and some guy says hey i would love to
trade you my lamborghini for your ford
mustang
right but let's say you paid 50 grand
for a ford mustang this lamborghini is
now worth a hundred thousand dollars
the guy just loves to afford mustang so
much as willing to do the trade
so effectively when you're when you're
making that trade or making that swap
there is a gain in what you've made even
though you didn't really physically
receive the cash in pocket
yeah so if you do like they have they
have different ways of doing like shape
shift for example
or if you're just doing an exchange
going from aetherium to
say snx snx or another coin or something
like that
so i have to pay taxes on that you
technically what you're supposed to do
is report the gain
of that pay the tax on it but now your
coin is is riding based on that
we are so [ __ ] boys
that's why it's kind of [ __ ] up right
because you know why you
like let's say in my situation
let's say uh i i uh
quote unquote lost a quarter mill right
i
only report three grand
maximum to my personal income loss
throughout the year so like indefinitely
three grand if i never go back into the
crypto space every year i i get to write
off three grand
but if i make any gains i [ __ ] get
taxed on that
what the hell yeah but it's not double
right so like
up until 250 000 i don't
pay taxes because i if if that was
already taxed so i get to get make gains
up until that point withdraw them
and i already i'm fine but if i get over
that
then yeah wow then you pay the tax on it
so like for
example let's say in one year i make
half a mill
i'm only tax on 250 000 but
you know it's like that what sucks is
every year you can't balance it out
is this all true does that check out
everything you just said fact check it
so in the fact-check way so technically
there's a couple of moving pieces to it
so when you have a capital gain either
long term or short term
you pay the tax on that capital gain now
if there's a capital loss
that's built in let's say for example
you had a quarter million of losses in
one year
now joe is absolutely correct the only
amount that you could actually show
reflecting on the tax return
is three grand the remaining two hundred
and forty seven thousand of that
long-term capital gain or capital loss
gets carried over and so everyone like
80 years hypothetically if you're not
doing
any other trades i see so if you do a
trade in the next year and you make
let's say 80 grand in profit that gets
wiped off against that
that long-term capital loss or 247 for
the remaining 247
okay so there is ways to kind of eat it
up the challenge with with crypto is
because a lot of folks typically have
more activity in it than
in their traditional like investment and
things are a little bit muddy now with
people like trading acting on robin hood
and all that stuff
there's a lot of different ways where
you could set yourself up if you're a
little bit more of an active investor
let's say a day trader or a swing trader
or a technical trader
where now you can use what we call
professional trader status
and number one if you elect that in the
like we call it mark to market you could
take unlimited losses
as opposed to three grand i think we're
gonna need that
might be a good thing how do you how to
get marked as a professional trader
so you have to you have to have a trade
on a daily basis and you have to prove
that you're doing it on a regular basis
and it could be a dollar
it doesn't really matter oh okay you
have to prove that you're actually
actively in the market
now if you're if you bought bitcoin you
didn't sell for like six months and
that's your only trade
you're just a casual investor right but
i don't feel casual because there's a
lot of money involved
so there's a lot of things that you
could do with that right once you once
you define that or once you like
create that that election that
professional trader status
you can now also offset your profits by
like i got clients at daytrade they have
this huge battle station with six
monitors and
electric and high-speed internet and
they have this office built up for it
now we're like hey you can use those
expenses to offset your gains
and ride that as a business expense as a
professional trader
and then if you're mark to market it
allows you take unlimited losses as
opposed to three grand per year so
there's a lot of moving pieces
but everyone's situation is different so
i'm just kind of like throwing a ton of
stuff out there
but and every situation is unique to the
person and you got to figure out
everything
correct so a little disclaimer
everything i share with all of y'all is
just basic general information obviously
you'll want to see your personal tax
advisor
um to make sure it fits your situation
taking your [ __ ] to the bank bro
i'm writing everything you just said no
i can't believe you know about this [ __ ]
this is fantastic that's kind of what
i'm learning like in this space
there's no general rule like
that can work for everyone because it
depends
on you know what kind of profession they
have what their life goals are
like you know how they get taxed all
this stuff is so
different and then you know that's why
like you know uh when we talk to our
financial advisor
it's so difficult for him to just go
this is what you should do
because you have to have a goal first
and like this is what i want
yeah that makes sense so in in going
back to like what you are you're
you're an accountant and then you do uh
like financial advising
and things like that and you said you
specifically focus
on business owners and and you help them
like grow or whatever
i see so what would that typically look
like
like what do you do to help them get to
that next level yeah
so it's been a real interesting
evolution of my business over the last
couple of years
um it first started off it's just doing
retail tax preparation i had three i had
four offices 40 employees we're doing
like
2500 tax returns per year so you're
doing like your own h r block type of
thing we were actually a liberty tax
service so we had four
my my oh that's your company they're not
my company directly we have a franchise
yeah oh okay okay but that's pretty yeah
known yeah
so at that point like what was really
interesting is i had business owners
that came in every single year
and every time i'd ask them hey would he
just spend on this and spend on this
they started looking up at the ceiling
and
recording their numbers from the and i'm
like the numbers aren't up there
and i started realizing that a lot of
folks had a lack of clarity on where
they stand in their business
and the challenge is if you don't know
where you stand you can make appropriate
financial decisions
so when i moved out to california um
about six seven years ago
at that time i was like i want to evolve
my business from just being this general
thing to helping people specifically in
small businesses because i was an
entrepreneur for years
i made a ton of mistakes and my
objective was like not that people
repeat all the
all the stupid mistakes that i made and
then so we first started off by doing
general bookkeeping and general tax work
but as we kept evolving we started being
in more creative conversations
so i had one client that i sold his
business to a private equity company for
example i had another client that we
basically rescued his accounting
to get him in place to bring on
investors and then it really started
coming together where i realized that we
could either be a commodity like an hr
block and just do tax returns
where i could be a trusted advisor and
help people really scale and grow their
business
so what we really focus on now is we
come in
as a strategic partner in terms of
taxation and also strategic partner in
terms of finance so a lot of folks to
hire me either as their fractional cfo
or their strategic like accounting team
and we take care of all the books and
the finances and
give them clarity on their finances and
then folks also harrison to be like a
tax advisor so we don't normally always
replace like their tax professional
but we come in and say based on where
you're going here's a couple of things
that we see because we're looking
forward the challenge with the tax base
is the accounting space everyone's
looking into back
that's retrospect retrospective you're
driving down the street but you're
looking in the rearview mirror
that's what most tax preparers are doing
there's nothing wrong with that just the
nature of the business
it's like they're looking more about
what you spent last year
instead of thinking of how can you spend
next year better where you can grow it
by times five
correct do you lose your [ __ ] during tax
season
man yeah it's because my father-in-law's
a cpa and he's a different person
for like four months yeah i don't even
hear from my cousin and from like
january to april
it's a challenge i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna lie i mean i've been in
the tax base now this will be my 11th
tax season doing it
and every year there's always more
nuance to it
the irs drops the ball a couple of times
filing dates change
we just had covid where things were
extended and so it's never it's
it's kind of interesting because it
keeps you on your toes but for me as a
business owner
and also an accountant and tax advisor i
realized i needed to build a proper team
around me
to help me handle it and the unfortunate
thing is most entrepreneurs
they tend to run solo and especially as
an asian american my dad was like
hey you know the way to get ahead is
like do everything yourself control
everything because you'll save money but
the problem is when you do that you
artificially restrict yourself to
a certain level of growth and then you
you get maxed out because you only have
so much bandwidth
right so just in the last two years
between me and my son traveling we lived
in bali for two months lived
we drove cross country for two months in
our suv i had to start scaling out and
bringing a team on and the moment i did
that
tax season's still really stressful
don't get me wrong but it's a different
level of stress as opposed to
[ __ ] i got like 18 tactics i gotta do
today or like i'm
sol so it's more like building that team
around you helped you
balance out life better yeah and i think
that's really important i think what
happens is we have this
this weird i guess idolatry in america
we think that everyone is a unicorn and
you hear
you're self-made all the time right like
kendall jenner self-made billionaire she
wasn't self-made her mom supporters she
had her family behind her she had a
whole team
where people look at elon musk as he's
some sort of unicorn
right and the challenges is
entrepreneurs are driven at the
direction of like
hustle grind and do as work as hard as
you can kind of thing
but they're not like taught this this
little tweak of hey if you bring in the
right people around you
hire for your weaknesses and focus
purely on what you're really good at
i mean you could really grow a wonderful
business so you're saying you're saying
like elon
didn't really do that much
i think yeah i think that's that's a
good point he knows how to hire great
people
i'm not a big elon fan um i mean i
respect what he's accomplished
but there's also a lot of things that
i'm not a fan of what he's done
right but he's he's in the people they
look at him differently like in business
right because you know there's a lot of
hype like there's a lot of the reason
why
everything is going the way it is he's a
great marketer he's an amazing
perception person which is different
from
you know things that have quote unquote
real value right like in the marketplace
and i think that once you understand
that in business
there is this gray area well is he is he
being
honest or not i don't know you know so i
i get that but then to the rest of the
world
uh they see this person pushing the
boundaries and he's like hey he's like
us
and and he's fighting for the little man
and i like him so i think
with that there's a disconnect between
what business owners and p entrepreneurs
feel
of each other and the general public
when they look at
you know business guys yeah i don't like
his space stuff but i like i like the
flamethrower [ __ ]
yeah i'm all about the boring company
stuff yeah yeah yeah and it's tequila i
mean i'm a tequila
i haven't had it tesla tastes
so actually okay so tequila i don't
really have the greatest relationship
with it and i think it was just because
of a poor choice a couple of years ago
so one of my friends she has a beautiful
home in in irvine california that's
where i live
and she was having an end of your
christmas party and so
i was over with all my gym buddies and
like all the the guys and girls over
there
and me her husband was just a big white
dude and my buddy issues this gigantic
mexican guy
they all decided to ha let's have a
drinking test and i'm just like this
five six vietnamese dude right
so the way that the way that the
drinking contest worked was
you would drink and then you breathe
into a breathalyzer whoever
had the highest amount won that round
what the [ __ ] it's the most white trash
thing i've ever heard
apparently and now so here's the
challenge number one
we would all take shots were you guys
watching wrestling too
my drink of choice apparently is don
julio there's this bottle right this
like glass bottle that comes over and
it's my favorite pretty good drink it's
delicious right
and then so the way it works is somehow
i always was the one who breathed last
and somehow my buddy issues the biggest
mexican guy breathe first not realizing
it when you drink
and you do breathalyzer when you breathe
right after drinking you get the highest
amount
but for me and each time you breathe
through it it had to reset for two three
minutes
so for me always being last it would
reset for 10 minutes by that time all
the alcohol is on my breath
next thing i know i've consumed the
entire bottle of don julie on one
sitting
and we're going out to my buddy's garage
he's showing me his car
and and the whole time like i am not
cohesive
not cohesive at all i'm fertilizing my
friend's lawn
all the things i ended up like like
using her toilet like you couldn't tole
all night and then so i had a little bit
of a breakup with uh with tequila yeah
don
but you still love her that's what you
said you know i love her yeah tequila's
delicious
i love it you you love taxes and tequila
taxes and tequila
[Music]
so